ALS or amyotrophic lateral sclerosis is
an extremely debilitating and usually
fatal disease and it's a horrible
disease you have your motor neurons the
neurons that are essentially activating
your muscles telling your muscles when
to when to twitch or when to contract
and that these neurons these cells that
traverse that go from the from your
brain all the way to your muscle so
there's these unusually long cells they
go through your spinal cord they
degenerate they degenerate and as they
degenerate
there's no way to for your brain to send
the signals to your muscles to do the
things that your muscles need to do and
so your your muscles atrophy and so
that's actually where the first part of
ALS comes from the a in ALS amyotrophic
a means no or not or kind of the
opposite
Myo means is referring to muscle and
trophic is nourishment so this is one
way to think about is no muscle
nourishment but what's really happening
is that the muscles start to die away
because they're no longer to be there
they can no longer be activated because
I guess you could say the the wires are
motor neurons that would normally
activate them they degenerate
and what's especially horrible about
this it obviously causes paralysis
people lose control over basic things
including their speech is the whole time
that this is happening and this is
degenerating the individual in question
has has full mental awareness so they're
fully aware of what's going on in their
body so you could imagine it's a it's a
it's a fairly horrible thing for people
to go through and there have been many
famous cases of people with with ALS
most famously probably Lou Gehrig in
fact ALS in the u.s. at least is often
called Lou Gehrig's disease one of the
most famous baseball players of all time
he for the New York Yankees
he died of ALS really when he was about
my age and in his in his late 30s
Stephen Hawking he's one of the small
percentage of ALS sufferers who have
been able to live several decades past
his
diagnosis it affects it affects 1 to 2
out of 100,000 individuals each year so
if you were to imagine kind of a large
stadium of people in a given year you
would expect if you say there's roughly
a hundred thousand people here you would
expect one to two of them to get
afflicted with ALS and the reason why
there's it's important to have research
behind is it's very very not so well
understood disease people know what
happens they know that the motor neurons
degenerate but they don't know why it's
happening
there's scientists have identified some
genetic component to ALS for some of the
suffers for but for the majority they
can't identify a genetic component and
it's unclear what environmental
components are causing and although
people think there must be some
environmental components but as far as
most people can tell it just randomly
afflicts people once they kind of get
into their early middle age so it's a
really really horrible disease and it's
it's really important that people have
awareness for it and and that there is
an appropriate level of funding and in
case you're wondering yes I did take the
ice bucket challenge as well I have been
challenged by Sean O'Sullivan to do the
ice bucket challenge some about to do it
already
and I'd now like to issue the challenge
to three other people the other Salman
Khan famous Bollywood actor
Esther Cho who works with me at Khan
Academy and my kids who seemed too happy
to see myself get doused with cold water